[Musique]
elle les vacances continuent pour les
yvelinois et bien sûr de nombreuses
activités sont prévues bonsoir mélanie
poké qu'avez vous à nous proposer pour
votre sélection d'idées de sorties
alors vous devez vous en douter grégory
il ya beaucoup à d'animation une fois
encore je ne serai pas exhaustive le
premier rendez vous que j'ai à vous
proposer se passe à plaisir
l'association impro net organise un
stage de découverte de l'un près de
l'improvisation
il s'adresse aux jeunes âgés de 10 à 15
ans pendant cette semaine ils vont
pouvoir durant deux heures par jour
travailler des exercices d'improvisation
tout en s'amusant ils vont pouvoir
savoir mettre en scène des histoires
jouer des personnages interagir entre
eux créent aussi une cohésion entre dans
le groupe qui va être fort mais il reste
encore quelques places pour les
intéressés clou du stage les jeunes
artistes présenteront leur travail à
leurs familles et amis le vendredi on
continue mélanie avec les châteaux qui
sont aussi à la fête
et oui celle-là on part à rambouillet où
les équipes vous ont concocté une chasse
au trésor il va falloir trouver un
trésor ancestrale qui se transmet depuis
des siècles entre les propriétaires du
château vous serez aider dans votre
quête par une jeune historienne madame
pivert c'est un moment à vivre en
famille du lundi 17 au samedi 22 février
l'animation se fait par contre sur
réservation uniquement
et un dernier rendez-vous de châtelet on
va plus au nord du département et oui là
on part au château de maisons plus
exactement la magie du rococo va vous
être dévoilé à travers un atelier
vacances cet atelier commence par la
visite de l'exposition fantaisie pour un
palais et après c'est de se visitent un
moment de création manuelle les enfants
confectionneront un pop-up illusionniste
et bien sûr rococo c'est un moment à
vivre
les 14 19 20 et 21 février merci mélanie
pour ses idées de sorties on l'espère
avec un week-end plus cléments côté
météo pour d'autres suggestions vous
retrouve bien sûr dans votre émission le
7-8 ce loisir 7 après journal